[Music]
yes dominic
i have brought for you an apple not
to eat just to look at while i eat
right just you know because sometimes i
get caught short this morning i knew the
podcast was happening
yep i did the gym i missed my breakfast
and over here i was a little light
headed because hot in los angeles so
you've done the gym already already
did you go to the gym or did you jump in
the house jim came to me
now what did you work on today today was
legs and we're also doing a little bit
of core because
let me tell you you know you've known me
for 20 years now
i lean towards the side of skinny as
opposed to leaning towards the side of
chunky but during covid
as is my want i thought well yeah i'm
going to enjoy a little bit more pasta
yeah
some butter some pizzas get you know
just put on a little bit of
winter weight and uh the abdominals have
struggled have they so i'm now doing a
little bit more ab stuff and then today
we did this thing called do you know
what a
curtsy squat is yes across
the back of your leg right so one leg
stands the other one comes across and
back kind of diagonal and you
squat yeah so well you lunge
don't you lunge backwards yeah you don't
yeah you lunge backwards
you must be doing a lot of those type of
things for your
butt yeah i do a lot of squats we do
some lunges
yeah you got you got to keep your legs
and your core strong
my trainer was asking me about your knee
because he listens to the podcast hi
stevie
hello stevie and he said how's billy's
need doing i said it's all right he's
working on it
and i said he said what's it what type
of workout is he doing and i said well i
know he's doing a few things but i also
know he has the peloton
and stevie asked do you stand up on the
bike
i do occasionally because that works the
bum but if you don't standing up is good
stand up because if you're sitting down
that's all
thighs and you've got thunder thighs
that's your problem yeah yeah i know
thunder thought stand up more
compromised knees
and a tiny little ass thunder thighs
compromise look at the size of the tiny
pies
yeah we do like to call our asses pies
see it's the thing that it's a movement
see i can only get to there you see
well can i used to be able to go way
down to there
oh yeah right but no it just did there
well i just saw you do it
what's that one ah is it saw or just
tight
it's both see that that's as far as that
will go
this is going to be great for the audio
listeners what i'm doing
is i'm holding my leg around the shin
and pulling it towards my posterior
but this the posterior doesn't get very
close to the heel
no it doesn't well that's concerning
bills don't worry about it don't
worry about it hey an exciting day for
me i've already told you this but i'll
tell the listeners
stroke viewers i'm releasing two
wonderful uh
wild rattlesnakes today i thought you're
going to release two singles on the same
day
yeah like kanye west or something a side
in the b side yeah
uh two rattlesnakes that i've been
rehabilitating they they came to me with
some digestive problems they were not
interested in eating food so you didn't
have to get as much water in them as
possible
get them with a nice constant heat get
them nice and fit and healthy
sometimes you have to give them some
antibiotics to get some parasites out
didn't need two of these guys just
needed to get them safe get them well
get them hydrated
they now started to eat they're big and
fat and now i'll take them about
an hour and a half drive outside of los
angeles to a very steep canyon
and set him free and i'll tell you what
it's a wonderful feeling you open up the
little sealed bucket
pour him down the side of this canyon
brand new life
some little mouse somewhere i was gonna
hate that yeah
yeah that's true but i take him to this
very steep canyon it's absolutely
perfect for snakes
and a lot of other animals it's like a
deep trough
so no humans can go down there there's
no trails
and it's a paradise for animals because
they all live down there water pools
down there so they can get hydrated
and especially for snakes sit down at
the bottom wait for the food to come by
you didn't name them or anything do you
i don't name animals that i release
no but the ones that i keep i do
but uh these were two wild rattlesnakes
that i'd always planned on releasing so
no no names well done you've saved those
you've saved those snakes dom
yeah that'll be exciting um what else is
going on with you we were just talking
about
we had sports documentaries and you've
not you've not seen the last
dance no i i think i watched the first
episode
is it seen the first episode does he um
was it was he playing pennies against
the wall or something please against the
wall at some point
i've got a memory of that yeah but no i
didn't watch it
it's great yeah i love sports
documentaries i like them as well
although
i do think that uh basketball is sizes
we're definitely a scientist yeah
there's so there's no argument there
there's been a few anomalies in the
basketball world well not many right no
there was a guy called boykins that
wasn't very big
faithful sex i think there's something
around about that about our height but
most
even short basketball players now are
like
six four six five you have to be sure
could there
not be another league for basketball
well they dropped the basket
and everybody has to be under six foot
so you're suggesting
a crapper version of basketball a
faster would it be faster maybe faster
more exciting would it be more exciting
it might be more exciting
and certainly they'd have to what we're
going to do
the the basket comes down a foot right
but
the tall shoes as well no no
no keep the shoes as they are and then
but
see the the court will make that twice
the size
oh wow that seems really tough on the
little guys oh it's tough on them
yeah the probably the
the life cycle of the the
under six foot basketball player would
be about two years
yeah could you be exhausted exhausted
back and forward
back and forward but that boykins guy he
could slam dunk
on a normal sized net they should have
called him boinkins
boy can be honest but isn't that amazing
he's our height
yeah slam dunk do you feel sometimes a
little have you had
been on the brunt of some scientists not
really
hey sure ass get out i never even knew i
was on the shorter side
until i remember the day i was at
in a science class and we were learning
about
statistics and things i suppose yeah and
everybody got
weighed and measured and i was on the
bottom
10 percent
until that moment you didn't know i
thought it was tall wow
like the hobbits in uh lord of the rings
they don't think they're small they
think everyone else is abnormally tall
don't they well they are
yeah to a whole bit it's a good mindset
to have yeah and also a lot of the
really great actors out there
and not necessarily that tall no it's
actually
yep de niro hoffman
brando none of them tall no they're all
kind of
five seven five eight yeah all the great
um football players
well not all but a lot a lot of them
yeah maradona smallish
messy smallish change direction faster
yeah low sense of gravity
a low sense of gravity slow
what is the word oh thank you i like the
low sense
so like sense of growing if you just
like
ignore gravity a little yeah it doesn't
work so good i do think that
lionel messi does ignore gravity he's
very good doesn't he he's just signed on
to uh
spend the rest of his days at barcelona
took a 50
pay cut i think that's all right when
you're making that kind of money
brilliant
but what that tells you for someone like
messi to take a 50 paco is
i'm motivated to stay at this club i'm
not motivated by money
not motivated by a legacy or a name
outside of this club
his thing was i want to finish my career
at barcelona
my dad hi dad has been banging on for
like
i don't know a decade now ah messi's
coming to city
he's not put your kind of condensed milk
away yeah
shelve it we wouldn't be watching that
you won't be watching that at all
just wrap up your nuts i beg your pardon
your dad enjoys some nuts oh right
yeah no no hey those um boiled peanuts
that stephen colbert
uh suggested we try for billy and don
meet the world and then we went away
with
gotta be honest i threw him out how long
did they last
i wasn't sure and i gave them a smell
as it i like once i'd refrigerated them
and they just smelled a bit
yeah like moldy well i said to john
john the producer when he gave us the
extra ones
i said are they supposed to smell like
that and he said yeah
damp and damp and like a little vinegary
hold on john's got something to say uh
he
said that because they were soaked in
brine it's almost like a pickled
peanut so they should be able to last
theoretically forever
and they're put straight in the fridge
theoretically
forever like for the rest of time
so if a guy in the future and like a
far far like great great great great
grandson of stephen colbert
becomes an archaeologist in the future
and digs up one of those nuts and he'll
say
here's one of my great great great
grandfathers pickled nuts
i'll just get this into my black teeth
them into my mouth absolutely delicious
you'll see yeah if he ever digs up
the nuts that dom threw away
theoretically you could still eat them
so you're telling me because mine are
still in the fridge they still got yours
can i boil them tonight
you can't and if i get sick with violent
diarrhea
my first call will be you john yeah i'll
say
get round here mop his breath exactly
what colbert said he said these things
these things last
a lifetime so well he's a wise man he's
a wise man i'm sure he's like a young
wizard might i suggest if you're gonna
boil your nuts tonight yep
a couple of beers on the side there
maybe a modelo
oh maybe a pacifico i think it'd be nice
with a beer wouldn't it
it's great that's what uh and a salty
nut that's what stephen colbert said
a beer on the boat heading back after a
successful fishing trip
for me a successful fishing trip means
they've gone back in
for other people is something different
they're going photo opportunity
they're in back end again think so good
on you yeah why not
don't hiya had a fantastic game of
league of legends the other day
oh let's do the thing
you're a fantastic game and you would
know this because you were in the mid
lane when i was having it
we had two great games you know great
games but
i had one where i got 10 kills which is
very unlike me dom as
kaiser i think right you're right and
you remembered this week
to put down your visor and quickly drop
a frog
a drop a frog he fires around and then i
suck her back into my gills it's
important to have a frog when you're
playing kaiser
yeah that's great this friend of ours
that we're playing with
is so good that what he'll do is
he'll hit the enemy champions until they
only need one hit for you to kill him
and then he'll back off and go go on
them
and then you hit him and then do you
think that's why i got 10 kills
i think it's definitely the reason why
we're all playing a lot better and also
you said to our friend jake hey jake if
i'm going to go down in the bottom lane
with you maybe you can just give me a
few pointers
so as i was playing in the mid lane
concentrating on my stuff i could hear
him ever so often saying
okay great bills that's that's good just
stay in that position okay now we're
going to jump in okay now we're going to
go back to the shops
little things stuff i didn't know as
well he's like
look i put this down as a it will get
you healthy
i didn't know that little thing got me
helped yeah stand on it
and then he's saying if you kill this
person you get all this gold
i didn't know you get gold from killing
champions
yeah so it was very very helpful and
i've
i'm i could be a teacher now yeah that
was game one as kaiser
brilliant i was in the mid lane as ari i
think
did pretty good and then the second game
you played as lulu
i did i was supporting and you were
brilliant again you got a ton of assists
i was all right i like making people big
when i'm lulu yeah
there was two moments where we were in a
team fight whereas
because i always my seems to be a
catchphrase i go oh i'm in trouble oh
i'm dead yeah and i went oh i'm in
trouble oh i'm dead
and you went no you're gonna be massive
and then i survived
so it's great what that's good would you
prefer to get really good at kaiser oh
really good at lulu
at the moment probably lulu i like lulu
a lot she's brilliant
she's great i like chitons people aren't
rabbits
yeah it could be better that's so good
so what about elijah
wood well elijah would
um got in touch with us saying
i'm trying to play the game and we said
you're playing the wrong mode of the
game and then he said okay i'll play the
tutorial so he played the tutorial right
as lux okay ahri right and then since
then
yeah i texted him and said how are you
getting over there yeah
nothing nothing back crickets
that sounds like fun really yeah i think
the phone's trying to be a cricket isn't
it
yeah i think when that when your phone
rings like that the the actual tone is
called crickets
oh well that's what in there yeah um so
i think we're in stasis
yeah yeah yeah stasis we'll call it last
week i gave
him the size of an orange so i'm gonna
plumb
i'm gonna stick with the orange because
i think there's nothing's changed
nothing's changed
from the drastic improvement we had last
night
that's where we're at well i'll stick to
the plum as well but it's slightly
shriveled
like stephen colbert's nuts
yeah in my fridge well should we get
richard taylor on we had such an amazing
interview with richard taylor that we
split into two parts because we were
fascinated with what he was saying he's
a great conversationalist and he has got
cracking stories
let's get him on right then richard
taylor
billy i have been packing a suitcase
because i am heading away
on a little trip and one of the first
things that i've put in my suitcases
are my untucked shirts well i think
that's a very
wise call dom because i've got a couple
of those shots now
and i love them they're fantastic not
only do you not have to tuck them in so
they stay kind of wrinkle free but also
when you put them in your suitcase and
take them out at the end of your trip
there's not a crease on them lovely
yeah i love them and i didn't have
enough short sleeve shirts you know
polos
and they do that as well the short
sleeves really
nice cut they do a slim cut that is
absolutely beautiful dumb yeah you look
fantastic in your untucked shirt they
have shapes
of all sizes and they offer sizes from
small you know a little bit like us
to triple xl so any size that you are
there's an untucked shirt for you and
you probably find there's stores around
the
us of a as well there's 85 stores
nationwide fantastic so use the code
onion for 20
off your first purchase at untuckit.com
this morning billy yes after my workout
you know what i had
uh tell me a lovely bowl of magic spoon
cereal and i'll tell you why it has
between 13 and 14 grams of protein
in each serving and only four net grams
of carbs
well that's a great tip so rather than
having a protein
shake after you work out a nice bowl of
cereal yeah and zero grams of sugar it's
only a
140 calories a serving dom
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free
soy free low carb and
gmo free wow that's amazing and it's got
four flavors you've got cocoa frosted
fruity and peanut butter and what i like
to do and you do it as well yeah i add
the cocoa and the peanut butter the
chocolatey one and it becomes like a
chocolate peanut butter
cereal treat i love it dom so go to
magicspoon.com forward slash onion to
grab a variety pack
and try it out today and be sure to use
our promo code
onion at checkout and you'll save five
dollars
off your first order yeah and magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money
no questions asked remember get your
next delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com slash onion and use
the code onion
to save five dollars thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
well richard we could talk to you for
hours for hours
but let's let's jump forward because i
know that everyone listening out there
is is going to be yeah okay what the
hell
now it's great
we have to make sure that everybody all
our listeners watch
meet the people you have to find it and
watch it
and we'll talk about it on the show
another time
how was that for the longest plug for a
movie
but it's a it's a great one and it's
it's so worth watching if you can
if you can find out it's a brilliant
film but let's
let's uh you know all these people who
are hanging on your every word to talk
about lord the rings let me let me ask
you this one
kicking off question because so you guys
had to do an
extraordinary amount of things on lord
the rings wetter specifically did so
much
heavy lifting in that film but when you
sat down
with the creative team and with p in
in these initial conversations
what were the things that seemed to be
at the very top of the list of the
challenges for making
the trilogy of course everyone knows
that you're going to be making armor and
weapons and creating characters but what
seem to be
the toughest things to try and solve
initially
uh the plausibility of the world
is top of the list pete i don't even
know if pete said this or whether it's
just become
myth or we invented it i apologize if we
did but
someone said um i can't maybe it was me
to our crew i just can't remember but
imagine that you've taken a plane and
landed at the middle earth airport
just like you may land at an airport
anywhere in the world
you step off and the world is as
plausible
as the world that we see in front of us
in our real world
that that was critical to us pete spoke
from the earliest days about it not
being
a movie that required the actors to stop
mid
scene and wink at the audience just just
stay with us just buy
into it just go along for the journey
we'll get you there in the
end and i would argue that up until that
point
i won't say all fantasy movies because i
had not seen all of them but
most fancy movies did require the actor
to do that
it required you to sort of buy into the
suspension of disbelief at a significant
level because
the world was highly fantastical
now lord of the rings is highly
fantastical there's balrogs and foul
beasts for
you know forsakes but um
but the world in which those characters
exist
is a highly plausible world it is not
our world
but the architecture of the world has
been built with
similar technology and
physical realities as our own world the
costuming
is made of materials of our own world
and
and the creature the creatures have
physiological
similarities to our own world and that
that was an imperative and that was made
very clear from the very outset by pete
and so that put parameters around the
design
process but it also set
a challenge and expectation around
the manufacturing of everything that was
so
critical when you guys stepped into
the world that we were creating
collectively with the art department the
costuming team the props department etc
you stepped into a highly plausible
ecosystem you didn't step and go oh what
the hell is this
yeah you no you're absolutely right
richard and i can say
for the actors walking into
i'm thinking you know fangun forest
or moria maybe even more when
those places felt real and for an actor
that is incredible
to see the amount of art and work
that went into those sets makes the
actors job so much easier
and and if you don't mind me saying the
the
people involved the characters from
weta the love that they put into it
also as much as the sets and the art
of the actual set but the actual people
that we
met from weta and the love and passion
that they put into it
i think helped those movies as much as
anything else you know having those
people from wetter there
and how much they cared about it i think
translated onto the screen as much as
anything else
it's lovely of you to say many of those
people are still here
joe who would have uh looked after your
weapons on the
on the lord of the rings is still
looking after great many projects here
etc rob gillies is still here daniel
falconer of course many of those people
that you interacted with
and we did realize
that um it was never spoken of but i
think everyone involved
realized that this was our moment it was
our moment on the world stage to
try and try and imbue our
passion and our love of what we do into
something extremely special
and it's a well-worn adage now which
i've spoken to a number of times but i
stand by it still
today the reality is that the film
wasn't made by a single filmmaker of
course it was instigated couldn't have
happened without pete but
it wasn't made by a film company it was
made by a
population of people across new zealand
that embraced
this because i would suggest that no
matter what small town or city you guys
turned up in
the people that were involved whether
only for a day or for the seven and a
half
years were all equally
engaged at a passionate level with the
desire to see this thing work
and i feel that that was a huge
part of the success of of
of what we finally see in the movies
where you sit in the
in the cinema and you actually can feel
the love of the making of the movie
in the movie which is not something you
can say about all film
and obviously an extraordinary amount of
work
being done by your company alone richard
but
was there a moment for you personally
or you and tanya where you came home one
night
and you said you know what i i think
we've i think we're on to something here
you know you you watch something or you
achieve something you think
actually there's something special going
on
um uh
i think i think no one specific
date on it but it sort of grows on you
of course
from we the famous meeting at pete's
place
uh as the story goes he gave me a phone
call he says you better get around to
the house
uh grab the guys bring some fish and
chips don't forget the coke
i've got something to tell you right and
uh
the guys uh being christian rivers
daniel falconer
jamie biswarak warren mahi ben
watten tanya myself maybe there are a
couple of others i'm missing i apologize
to them
we we grabbed the fish and chips from a
fish and chip store that still exists
just down the road
grabbed the bottle of coke because we
couldn't drink we couldn't eat fish and
chips without the coke
and to end up ran around to peter's
house which is just seven minutes drive
from here
and we all sat on the floor eating fish
and chips together and he told us that
we're about to start
on the lord of the rings and
i i described it in the past at
that moment you you are slightly
pushed to the edge of a precipice and of
course
you have that inflection moment where
should i step back because i'm not
worthy of this
and leave others to to to do their part
and be involved but don't get too
involved
or do you simply step over the edge of
the cliff
and um and uh i never hesitated at that
moment to step
over the edge of the cliff i might
actually hesitate more today
because um back then my ignorance was
somewhat an
ally to me but um
what catches you from hitting the bottom
of the cliff of course it's the support
of the extraordinary people around you
only one-eighth of our staff had ever
worked on a film or tv show before when
we started on lord of the rings we had
to put together 158 people
and i think 38 of them had been working
with us
so but regardless that 158 people and
the confidence
you have in them is the thing that stops
you hitting the bottom of the cliff
the confidence i had in tanya as my
partner in the
people that were already with me with
the five or six
guys that were in the room with me on
that day and also
with the certainty of peter's leadership
and vision so um
[Music]
we actually never never it got really
hard as you could see it was really
tough
we're making a lot of stuff we're
running at a million miles an hour
arguably doing crazy crazy hours to get
that film made
but never once did tanya and i return
home
together in an evening and uh
suggest that this was too hard we sh we
should try and slow it down this is um
we we you know we shouldn't be doing
this never once did that even cross my
mind
such was the almost euphoric joy that i
felt every day to be involved in it
and respecting and appreciating how
extraordinarily fortunate we were
to have been invited to be involved in
it
billy you and i have very much been
enjoying the one dream act recently
you're right dom i love it very
entertaining
one dream it's a streaming app that
allows video
and learning experiences and you and i
both enjoy being entertained
whilst educated at the same time you're
absolutely right tom so there's classes
out there
for you and if there's anything in
particular that you're interested in
you might find it on one dream of course
there's things that you'd expect like
biology and history and
space travel but recently i've been
learning about bread making
and also ancient rome
and you know what dom there's probably a
few of our listeners who are interested
in the lord of the rings and there's a
few courses on there
whether you want to find out if hobbits
actually ever existed oh yes
or maybe where does frodo baggins sit in
that rich history of literature
oh fantastic explore all of your wonders
with one dream
trust us your brain will love it sign up
today to get our special limited time
offer a free month trial of unlimited
access
go now to one dream dot com forward
slash onion
that's w o n d r i
u m dot com slash onion for your free
month
trial onedrive.com slash onion
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating with a
therapist in under 48 hours it's not a
crisis line
it's not self-help it is professional
counselling
done securely online there's a broad
range of expertise available which may
not be locally available
in many areas and another great thing
dom this service is available for
clients
worldwide yeah you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your counselor
better help want you to start living a
happier life
today visit betterhelp.com
onion that's better h-e-l-p and join the
over 1 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help
that they are recruiting additional
counsellors in all 50 states
special offer for the friendship onion
listeners get
percent of your first month at
betterhelp.com
onion yes it's incredible and
it's it's funny having this kind of more
extended chat with you you see how all
the pieces fit together and
uh and uh in a weird way from the the
start when you said
you know i'm up here at 6 30 in the
morning or whatever
and you're still as happy doing that
because you took
the the boy taking that clay away from
the wall
and you made that your living and
that i think that's an amazing story and
i think the point um i i really want to
get across
is how important that is in the making
of these films
all your people in in weta who were
taking clay from walls or whatever their
start was
they took that into the making of those
films and it was
such an enormous part of it so much so
that i know that me and dom
came to visit weta your workshop so many
times during the making of the films
because that passion kind of no matter
how tired we got sort of filled us up
again
yeah you know watching someone making a
a shield or uh or when we got our
doubles faces
if you remember they made those sort of
masks and
and helmets this is going to be your
helmet all that stuff but that was the
passion that was wonderful wasn't it
yeah
and and the one that really blew me away
was the
um the uh miniatures
like was that always was that always in
the planning
those if you could explain what i mean
those miniatures of minnesota yeah
yeah well this is life before
a absolute confidence and visual effects
i just mentioned one thing if you think
about lord of the rings
another acknowledgement to peter's
i'm not sure what you'd even call it
skill ability confidence
vision is that we started the movie
and he left large gaps in the movie
where he was certain that
the visual effects that weren't invented
yet would
ultimately fill the gap the primary one
being gollum
right we originally talked about
shooting a prosthetic gollum an actor
dressed in prosthetics
in case the vision he had for gollum
didn't work out but in the first few
weeks we abandoned that
because the the we couldn't achieve
gollum prosthetically
because he needed to be so unique and so
pete just left
gaps where he was convinced the digital
effects arm of weta
would fulfill that responsibility and
indeed they did
another example is the large battles and
the huge numbers of soldiers
someone over at where the digital
started
designing a piece of software called
massive
that would one day populate the
battlefields with
tens and tens of thousands of soldiers
that you could never have done with real
actors in new zealand
so um but one area that
he was certain and we were certain were
going to be needed
was uh the environments uh in the first
film of
lord of the rings and i hope i've got
this right i apologize to everyone
because my
memory is quite vague on it all now um
there's only one digital environment
which is
ammon hen everything else is miniatures
we built miniatures
72 miniatures for the feature films
you build a miniature when there is not
a location in the world that you can
access or you want a
a location a piece of architecture in
the world
that doesn't exist yeah and
the first miniature we built was helms
deep
and that was a massive miniature if you
remember you guys we coined the phrase
bigotry's because we never built a
miniature i think
rivendell was the smallest miniature we
ever built and it wouldn't have fitted
in the room that we're in
but most of our miniatures touch the
four corners of a large sound stage
because a miniature you build a
miniature relative to the size
that the artist draws a person in the
miniature
and uh sorry in the world and alan
lee and john howe would draw these
monumental environments into which
they'd draw these
tiny little figures so that required us
to build
extraordinarily large miniatures we
built
um we built helms deep in miramax days
uh where miramax was still part of it
and
a story i don't think i've ever related
with respect to
um helms deep is uh
sadly for all of us miramax uh
decided to uh pull out of the project
um and we thought it was potentially
gonna fall over
pete set off around the world with a
portfolio of art that we'd put together
to try and find
another person he was allowed i think 30
days to put it into turn around
to try and find a studio that would pick
up the pro project
but over that 30 days a
you know a completely nice bloke from
miramax came
down but his task was to supervise us
to put everything into shipping
containers to ship
up to america and so we boxed every
marquette and by that stage we'd done
literally hundreds of marquettes
all the artwork that was easy enough the
costumes
it was hard on your heart but it was
easy enough to pack it we're putting
them all in kabul boxes documenting them
and so on but um the miniature of
ministerith we literally had to
cut with chainsaws into shipping
container sized
slices and start sliding them into
shipping containers
to ship to a warehouse in the u.s
but thankfully pete came home on the
29th
day or whatever it was and said that uh
new lane had picked up the project so we
pulled it all back
out and all got going again we re-glued
the miniature back together
and and uh started again goodness
grief well richard we're slightly
running out of time and we're gonna
we're gonna
we're gonna slightly change tac now
because billy it's our favorite part of
the show
oh we have it billy and dom are gonna
eat the world and this is based on a
recommendation of
our good friend richard taylor but while
we do this richard why are we bringing
these
amazing new zealand delicacy uh jeffers
um oh yeah i had a question for you
because obviously
oh nice we've got them at the same time
because obviously
you you've spent an extraordinary amount
of time
at these conventions in the same way
that billy and i
have and you've met fans from every
single corner
of the planet with with the profound
work that you guys have done at weta and
the amount of people that you've met
again is that is there any kind of is
there anyone in particular that stood
out to you
where their journey with
the movies or with the work that you
guys did kind of resonated in a way that
you could have never predicted
um yeah the first thing i would say as i
hope you both agree
i i'm better for it for having met those
people um
i don't like the way that i i've
witnessed
certain uh people within our industry
going
are the fans you know it's a bothersome
problem
that we have to deal with as part of our
job what a load of crap
we're very fortunate in fact our careers
only exist
because there are passionate individuals
that love what we do so much
and those passionate individuals when
associated with the sort of things that
we do
uh lord of the rings narnia um avatar
are probably exactly the same type of
people that we are
they love the same things we do they
they love what
you know so invariably they're almost
certainly going to be
people that we want to become friends
with and we've actually now had
we've made some of our closest family
friends
with fans um it even
seems the wrong word to use the word
fans they're enthusiasts
of of literature and film and by
some blessing we've connected with them
and they've come and stayed with us at
our home yeah uh
we we they send us christmas presents
and we send them chris
we hang out together when we get
together at conventions
such as the warmth and friendship and
and
in fact they're too many to list
because of uh and our life is richer
because of it
one of the things that we have been very
fortunate
is um i'm not plugging this or that will
sound like it our collectibles business
that's sitting behind us
the beauty of this business is it let us
stay attached to the eye
to to the world of middle earth well
beyond
the end of the movies and that
otherwise we wouldn't have gone to
conventions you you you've gone to
conventions
hired you know invited by the convention
because of what you did
in the movies we would have just buried
our heads and got on to the next project
but having a reason to go to the
conventions
has opened up our lives it's given us
the chance to take
sort of 10 to 15 people a year from the
workshop
somewhere else in the world and remember
many of those people have never traveled
outside of new zealand
and it's been enlightening to some of
our
team who have turned up at these
conventions
to discover that they are
so loved um that they
are important in the world to other
people that they're not just
technicians working away in a in a in a
workshop down in the bottom of the earth
and that's been joyous for us and
but if i answer your question more
specifically dom the
the the the stories that have impacted
us
and you've heard them as well um
i felt that i was lost in life and then
i watched the films i
felt that i couldn't carry on and then i
watched the behind the scenes mum and
dad
had told me there was no future in the
arts and i should become
a lawyer and then i watched the behind
the scenes
yeah and it gave me the strength to
change direction and uh
you know and that's really really lovely
and we
um sorry sorry richard i know you say
i was going to say that we have met so
many people as well great artists
who who will bring their art and shows
and
they will say they're they're
what they want to happen more than
anything is get to new zealand and work
at weta
it's such a sort of you know beacon for
them
because of the work that they've seen on
film and they think oh if i could just
get there
you know so that's a wonderful thing
it's a great answer
and we've hired a number of people from
convention floors over the years oh
that's great
well listen richard we know we know
we're gonna we'll let you
uh go but let's why don't you open that
bag of jaffas
we'll have a couple here and then billy
and i will talk about jeffers
once you've left because you're on it
we're on a little bit of a time i'm
going to eat one now so cheers to you
guys richard it's great to see you my
best to you give our love to tanya
and the kids thank you very much sorry
we kept you so long
but it's been wonderful to hear your
story it's really wonderful richard and
lovely to see you
great all the best you guys lots of love
to everyone there at wit uh
richard and hopefully we'll get to new
zealand soon and we can have a cup of
tea in person
yeah very good wouldn't that be lovely
billy and dom eat the world well billy
that was the marvelously talented
richard taylor there
isn't he great or as i like to call him
richard taylor
that's very good tom yeah the head of
wetter now if you guys know anything
about special effects for the last what
30 years wetter have been
doing a lot of those things that you
guys love
narnia lord of rings hobbit mastering
commander
avatar it goes well i'm still dog it
goes on and on yeah because on and on
tom
no they're amazing not only that they
are amazing
he recommended to us a sweetie that
billy and i ate
a lot in new zealand called jaffers
which we're going to talk about in a
second we had to let richard go he's
just about to start his working day
he's very busy but richard and anyone
that's listening from weta
billy and i both send you love we look
forward to seeing you in new zealand
soon
we'll talk to you in a bit right billy
let's get into it
jaffa's jaffas from new zealand of old
places now we can't can't eat them yet
although i really do want to
jaffas are one of the most notorious
most famous spherical suites from the
islands of new zealand
exactly um i think they were modeled on
uh mars the red planet great call there
i'm not sure if that's true but now
there's no particular
scent to it well a little a small
scent an orangey scent that nearly went
right up my nose there you gotta be
careful of that you could uh you could
suffocate can i eat it yet no don't eat
yeah we're going to read some stuff out
about
jaffa's new zealand registered trademark
for a small round suite consisting of a
solid orange flavored chocolate center
with a hard covering of red
colored confection they're called
jaffa's dom
after the jaffa orange yes a kind of
small slightly sweeter orange
and orange and chocolate is one of the
great flavor combinations in fact you
were probably the first person in my
life to introduce
slightly strange flavor combinations to
me because you in new zealand told me
that i should try
strawberries and balsamic vinegar and
doesn't it work
it works fantastically well dom don't
look at that just now right now
because i'm gonna get you to do some
things that involves numbers
and also close my eyes
the amount of jaffa's in an average
packet no you can look at a jaffa if you
want go on
what is the diameter of that jaffa
in centimeters yes diameter that's the
length of it across
i'm not telling you about a diameter i
think is the length of it a length of it
across i'm going to say
1.5 centimeters you absolute
did i get it yeah you ready no i didn't
i honestly
i honestly didn't didn't you really i i
swear i didn't i'm pretty good at
measuring i just don't want him she told
me not to do it he got too excited
no talk about it talk about it how does
it taste never eat a jaffa too quickly
you know the rules it's like i like one
two orange chocolate
crunchy on the outside your mouth closer
to the mic no somebody told me not to on
instagram could you get your mouth full
away
um
you've got an orange chocolate that
melts in the middle and surrounding it
a crunchy sweet shell that doesn't melt
as fast so you're left with a kind of a
bitey crunchy and the cool thing is i've
had these in my hand for a couple
minutes now
they don't melt they do not melt that's
what i'm just trying here's them
wait i'll try another one all right
there you can make your own jaffa
milkshake by mixing jaffa chocolates
with milk and ice cream in a blender
now tell me dom is it not true that you
could make anything in a milkshake by
mixing it with milk and ice cream in the
blender that's cool you can make like a
pilchard milkshake i mean if you had
minced meat you could make a mince meat
milkshake
if you mix it with milk good ice cream
and a blender let me tell you let me
tell you this
the jaffa is one of the few british
inputs based on the popular
english jaffa cake
kind of a biscuit isn't it really which
combines orange and chocolate with a
giant sponge base
that explains why australian new zealand
jaffas are small balls of chocolate
covered with hard orange coating because
they're trying to replicate
a jaffa cake can i just say a jaffa
chocolate from new zealand
with a jaffa cake from britain and a
lovely cup of tea
whatever should we give it scores before
you do that i'm going to give you
a point at me while holding a jaffa you
know the rules i'm going to give you a
fact
why is the jaffa cake which you said is
more of a biscuit
or a cookie cookie why is it called a
jaffa cake
why do the people that make it want it
to be a cake
can i do you know the answers i'm going
to take a guess here
i think the people making jaffa cakes
base
it on a cake on the thickness
of the thing itself is that right
no good
[Laughter]
they want it to be a cake because the
tax
the taxis are less on a cake than a
biscuit
really i was almost gonna get it right
let's give it scores
first i never know the cat categories
flavor
flavor well here we go get close to the
mic get you
get that lovely now i like it when you
chew it
um taste that's a good flavor out of 10.
i've got some in here in my in my breast
pocket
i'm giving it an 8.6 out of 10. it's a
fantastic combination
it's almost as good as jamming peanut
butter orange and chocolate and that as
you said that crunchy thing where it
leaves the crunch in your mouth
even after the chocolate's gone it's a
9.3
my goodness 9.3 okay the the look the
aesthetic i mean that is
that's pretty classic it looks like like
you said it looks like a miniature mars
doesn't it
don't choke almost back into my bridge
park
it's a simple classic shape
i'm gonna say i'm giving it a solid nine
you can't beat that it's an orange ball
i mean it's absolutely and i love the
color
although it's a bit more red than orange
i would say you've had red balls before
i have yeah and it's so surprised
centimeters diameter i guess that hand
on my heart i'll give it an 8.2
and then finally usefulness
which i know is your favorite guy it's
just hard to quantify the usefulness of
this i mean it's great as a
as a confection but and it says you can
make milkshakes out of it but i'm going
to demote it
do that mean there's not a huge amount
of usefulness
although it's travel size if you
you got it in your pocket you could go
on a train most of it doesn't gla
yeah that's good pointy but glass go to
london you'd still have a few in your
pocket no problem
lovely i'm gonna give it a i'll give it
a four
for useless yeah it's not not useless
useful it's not
crazy yeah so a six out of ten for
uselessness
and a four out of ten for usefulness
cool
that was japanese eyes not done
6.2 for usefulness guys sorry about the
screaming but too many jaffas will
actually raise the volume of british
people
i love it they're so tasty that was it
fantastic yummy stuff get some more
jaffas well done i think we should leave
it there what a fantastic show wasn't it
didn't you enjoy it i absolutely loved
it a wetter special and we'll see you
guys next week but make sure you rate
review and subscribe to the friendship
onion
thank you everyone turtles
[Music]